I love a great party but I hate bad food
and often the two things go together I
think one of the reasons is that home
Cooks get intimidated by the thought of
cooking for large crowds so they give up
and serve shop walk food instead but
trust me with a bit of planning and
great recipes it's easy this is my
Ultimate Party food first up a great
brunch for a crowd spicy Mexican eggs
for a sophisticated party lunch you can
pre-prepare beetroot cured salmon and a
chocolate mint cake little sheets of
glass beautiful my eldest daughter Megan
will be helping me rustle up some
amazing dishes for a relaxed Ramsay
get-together that's okay with
irresistible Smoky pulled pork don't
tell Mom thank you
simple but delicious sides of broccoli
slaw and crushed potatoes with spring
onions and gruya cheese
I've never had this before it's so good
these are my ultimate party recipes that
will entertain and sustain a house full
of guests for breakfast lunch and dinner
starting with the breakfast that can't
fail to get your guests fired up and
ready to party spicy Mexican eggs
this is a very classic Mexican style
brunch dish bold Kick-Ass flavors slice
the chili seeds in
garlic sliced nice and thinly
tablespoon of olive oil
I'm a big fan of brunches and if you get
it right a great brunch you can see
you're right through to dinner now to
start the sort of spicy fragrant tomato
sauce get your cumin in there
garlic chili roasted cumin red onions
already sounds Mexican
once that starts getting really nice and
crispy in with your tomatoes
that are embarrassed using good canned
tomatoes I do all the time cooking at
home
Now by reducing that sort of come down
to a delicious paste leave that to
simmer
next canned beans called black beans
these are authentically Mexican but
cannellini beans or chickpeas will work
just fine just rinse them a little bit
of water
that is beautiful turn off the gas and
just let it absorb leaving the dense
beans to luxuriate in the spicy tomato
sauce will allow them to soften and soak
up all the flavor
next oil and season an oven proof dish
for my spicy egg brunch to baking
I'll just get some of that oil
around the outside
take your corn tortillas slice them in
half and then just stick them to the
side
these are a staple in Mexico
take one and place that in the center
get your mix and place that on top of
the tortilla
spread that out nice and smoothly lift
up those little flaps I want that crisp
shell on the outside
now your eggs and cheese get the base of
the egg and just make a little hole in
there and then crack
the egg into the
again use a little point
put your egg in there one
two
three
four
five
and one in the middle
gently crack and get the egg to sit
inside almost like it's a little dug out
and then one for the center
it's got a really nice rich delicious
strong Montgomery cheddar I want a grape
the tortilla shell as well so get
generous with it on the top and we'll
season that with these little babies
little chili flakes they're my little
secret weapon and they're going to spice
up that egg just salt
a touch of pepper
sit that in the oven to bake for eight
to ten minutes and 180.
[Music]
[Applause]
that smells incredible
just a little bit of coriander to finish
it off and that for me is what brunch is
all about let's go
a fantastic fiery brunch to get your
party started spicy Mexican eggs and a
crispy tortilla shell
[Music]
coming up my ultimate food for lunch or
evening party
but first here's a closer look at the
key ingredients you'll need and a few
pointers on what to look for when you're
buying them
[Music]
chocolate the ultimate comfort food
addictive and indulgent the chocolate
making process begins by grinding
roasted cocoa beans
quality chocolate should contain at
least 70 cocoa solids it should give a
distinctive crisp snap when broken and
start melting in your hand after just a
few seconds and there'll be no skimping
on the quality for my party lunch
chocolate mint cake
pork shoulder is an easy to cook flavor
some joint and can be bought on the bone
or rolled It's relatively cheap price
makes it a great choice when you're
feeding a crowd marbled with fat to keep
it moisture and cooking it's also the
cut of choice for barbecue pulled pork
known affectionately in the U.S as
Boston butts I'll be cooking my
delicious version of this meltingly good
export as the star guest for my dinner
party
[Applause]
sodium chloride or salt is a mineral
essential to human life it's also one of
the most widely used seasonings in the
world it's lack of Aroma belies its
strong taste which both enhances the
natural flavor of food and stimulates
our taste buds this seasoning of all
seasonings is processed in various ways
and comes in all different colors and
forms but for me the finest in flavor is
crystallized sea salt the product of
evaporated seawater and is what I'll be
using to cure my salmon the main course
for my super simple but spectacular
party lunch
I think the best dishes for lunch
parties are the things that everyone can
help themselves too I also prefer dishes
that pack a really big flavor punch and
look impressive party food shouldn't be
subtle here are a couple of dishes for
my ultimate lunch party
the secret behind during salmon is in
the flavoring you're curing it with for
a hint of the Exotic and aromatic my
favorite starting point is to grind
coriander seeds
coriander seeds are citrusy it's got
that nice orangey flavor and it goes
brilliantly well with salmon
mix that with your salt and your sugar
it may look like a lot of salt and sugar
but once they've done their job of cold
cooking or curing the salmon most of it
will be washed away
next the greatest zest of two oranges
fresh pepper
and then mix in one of my favorite
ingredients grated beetroot
beetroot gives a really nice sort of
Rooty earthy flavor great for curing it
stains the salmon as well and it just
elevates it
now
you'll see what's happening now with a
beetroot the salt and sugar breaking it
down see how wet it's becoming now that
beetroot is ready for the salmon
if you've got a big party 10 or 20. you
get a whole side of salmon fill it and
get it pin boned by a fishmonger if it's
six or ten guests then this Chunk in the
middle is like the sort of middle part
of a fillet steak The Best of the Best
pour on your beetroot and basically what
we're going to do now is sort of pack it
with all the beetroot and look at that I
mean it looks fantastic
next cover your beet Rooty salmon with
climb film take your tray lightly press
and they get something substantial
something heavy a pot
or pan or some tins the weight on top
just speeds up the process
[Music]
in the fridge to cure for at least eight
hours or even better overnight
[Music]
to follow my deliciously light and
simple salmon
a devilishly indulgent dessert nothing
beats a great cake a sort of a show-off
trophy for party foods I'm going to make
the most amazing flourless chocolate
cake but with a Twist first thing first
make the caramel flatten the sugar never
stir a camel rule number one now keep
the pan nice and flat
I'm going to flavor this caramel with a
little bit of mint give it a little chop
sprinkle that into the caramel
don't get the caramel too dark just nice
and light a little teaspoon of oil onto
the tray and rub that in
and then pour out
your camera if I was making a caramel
sauce then I'd put butter and cream into
the caramel but I want this nice minted
brittle running through my cake whilst
the candle comes down on a tray I'm
going to make my cake
first melt good quality dark chocolate
in a bammary
eating it directly in the pan would
destroy the cocoa fats always in a bowl
over boiling water in a mixing bowl
sugar two whole eggs and three egg yolks
whisk until beautifully light and creamy
and the color changes to a light yellow
the more you mix the eggs and the sugar
a lighter that texture in the center of
the chocolate cake next melt some butter
into your warm dark chocolate and stir
puts that really nice Sheen velvety rich
and tasting amazing add that to your
sugar and your eggs
hmm
I give that a really good mix
and when you're making flourless
desserts it really is important to work
harder incorporating air especially with
the yolks and the sugar that natural
height needs to take place at the
beginning look at that looks like the
perfect chocolate ganache
then separate four egg whites into a
bowl
[Music]
now make sure you've got two thirds of
the way there with your whites and then
just sprinkle in your sugar it's almost
like a meringue and the firmer you make
these now the more it will elevate your
cake in the oven
foreign
[Music]
that's what you call a stiff peak
in with the whites
before I start mixing that I'll get my
camera
just start breaking that up it's a
little glass sheets of glass beautiful
and save some of your minty caramel
shards for decoration and use a rolling
pin to break up the rest into small
pieces sprinkle that in
so as we start to slice that chocolate
cake you'll come across that nice crunch
take your cake tin
make sure it's lined with the grease
with paper
on the bottom nicely greased pour this
in
sharp Taps on a hard surface or rid your
cake mixture of any air pockets that
could create holes in your cake
sit that in the oven
180.
after 35 minutes my chocolate mint cake
is cooked and whilst it cools down I can
whip up a peppermint cream topping
[Music]
add sifted icing sugar and a few drops
of peppermint extract to double cream
and whisk until it's just holding its
shape
[Music]
spoon your minty cream on top of the
cake leaving a small border free to make
it easier to cut for a cake that can't
fail to attract attention at your party
scatter over the remaining caramel mint
shards
[Music]
now to unveil my incredible beetroot
cured salmon
offer the weight
that's right
and look what's happened to the salmon
absolutely beautiful
and just tell how delicious that's going
to be with this sort of Sheen give that
a little rinse and cold water
with your kitchen roll Pat it nice and
dry
beautiful
traditionally cured salmon would be
sliced into large thin pieces like
smoked salmon but I like to cut mine
Into Thin strips it's easier and it will
show off its beauty
slice down get to the skin and then
flick your knife out
that for me is a much better way of
eating cured salmon
look at the difference the colors that
nice dark Rich ruby red
now when you've got cured salmon this
good trust me you just need a salad
melbour toast or some stunning bread
look how many slices of salmon we've got
and that's the secret for me to any good
party a couple masterpieces simple
straightforward ingredients but done
properly
foreign
[Music]
cured salmon and for dessert a Divine
chocolate mint cake party food with the
wow factor
[Music]
when you work in a restaurant your job
is to make sure people have a great time
you're there to make sure they're
enjoying themselves believe me after 20
odd years of the business I've got
experience in this department and the
golden rule for successes don't get
intimidated get organized here are three
of my ultimate dishes for a great
evening party
[Music]
if there's one thing all the Ramsay
children love it's a good family party
and my eldest Megan is going to help me
with the party piece
mouth-watering Smoky pulled pork with a
spicy chipotle mayonnaise
[Music]
that is the most amazing pork butt
butts away butts away now this is
incredible there's the shoulder yeah and
look there's the shoulder blade if you
go through here there's a knuckle there
that's connecting the top and that's why
it's cool but the slower you cook it the
more juice it is and it's great for big
parties because you just come along and
get your fork and shred it a delicious
Smoky mayonnaise and you're away onions
into half and half again okay I'm Gonna
Leave the roots on okay because I want
this to sit underneath the port
it gives a chance to cook evenly it
doesn't get dry in the bottom really
important okay now I'll peel the garlic
okay I'd like you to crush the garlic
we're gonna make a really nice little
paste
okay
come on Mickey
come on come on come on nice good girl
one more Crush
come on
cut there now this
is a beauty paprika smoke paprika I love
it so three nice tablespoons in
okay two large tablespoons of brown
sugar
salt place and pepper
[Laughter]
so I'm going to form a nice paste now
olive oil in
is that some thyme in there so we got a
sort of fragrant rub time stalks
underneath
so that's even more flavor going on the
bottom
pour that all over it
now this is where you've got to be
really quick
okay
I've rubbed that massage it in almost
that's exactly that
smells amazing we'll see just drizzle a
little touch of olive oil on top of that
for me
I keep the pork nice and moist
lovely like some of the best party
dishes the marinating the pork shoulder
can be done days in advance so if I was
doing this for a Sunday and start
marinating Thursday Friday so it gets
even tastier right it's quite easy as
well to make it's very easy five and a
half to six hours in the oven at 140.
while I pork butt slowly roast Meg and I
are going to pimp some shop bought
mayonnaise I don't like just plain
mayonnaise there's so many things you
can twist yeah there's so many things so
many exciting you can do with it right
salt pepper and
no touch of Honey sweetness yeah
sweetness but there's some meat coming
okay and I've got a little bit of you
know this Chipotle smoked Chipotle paste
I love that once you've made this
dressing you know it can sit in the
fridge great for open sandwiches yeah
can you use it for any sandwiches really
any sandwiches but goes brilliantly well
with pork now just have a little taste
a nice spoon of mustard
so that's a nice spicy mayonnaise
after five and a half hours in the oven
our pork is nearly ready just time to
knock up a couple of tried and tested
party favorites first deliciously simple
cheesy crushed potatoes
cut potatoes into even chunks and
submerge in salted boiling water skins
and all
meanwhile finely diced sweet pickled
gherkins or cornichons
trim and finely chopped spring onions
and Grate some nutty gruya cheese
when the potatoes are cooked through
drain roughly crush and add your spring
onions and gherkins
season to taste and gently combined
before a final sprinkling of grated
Greer
potatoes are equally delicious served
hot or cold
now I want something sort of raw like a
slaw something quite refreshing yeah so
I'm going to make a really nice fresh
broccoli salad now these are called
florets that's the best part of the
broccoli okay the bit that everybody
wants once they're off I'm going to
slice the broccoli
okay never had raw broccoli before it's
always been cooked when you dress this
with the dressing it's incredible now
little Seasons early on
yeah okay now for the dressing fresh
yogurt in teaspoon of sugar please die
a little smile
cider vinegar there you go
you finally chopped it up
in with the broccoli so
delicious
roasted almonds into the broccoli
carrots I love them that gives that nice
sort of chewy texture right lift up your
bowl please nice and gently
half of that in the middle please thank
you and stop and then mix that up with
me
okay
a little taste
so good and it's a kind of salad that
doesn't Wilt a couple of hours later
it's still crunchy because the
broccoli's raw raw broccoli salad
Chipotle now let me be the pork out for
this look at this Megan honestly that is
amazing it's beautiful that is
incredible
[Music]
now that goes to the table like that a
delicious
before we go to the table just a little
bit honestly
don't tell mum thank you
I'm gonna do it
now
so yeah you promised me you don't give
the recipe to your boyfriend that's good
this is my ultimate easy party dinner
melt in your mouth slow cooked Smoky
pulled pork with a spicy chipotle
mayonnaise
I'm quick simple size of crushed cheesy
potatoes and a light and healthy
broccoli slaw deliciously yummy dishes
that will have your family friends and
work buddies coming back for more right
[Music]
I love the chocolates
wow the sauce is a bit spicy dad nearly
blew my head off
there are loads more great home cooking
recipes on my app cook with me you can
find it in the App Store good luck
[Music]
foreign
the price of ingredients seems to be
going through the roof at the moment so
whether you've got a big family like me
or you're just cooking for yourself it
pays to keep an eye on costs but that
doesn't mean you have to compromise on
Taste My ultimate Thrifty recipes prove
that whatever your budget you can still
cook Sensational food first a breakfast
to cheer you up whatever your budget my
mum's Thrifty cinnamon eggy bread with
quick stewed apples for lunch on a
shoestring superb Smoky bacon sweet corn
and potato soup it's amazing how cheap
the ingredients are they go into this
and helping me cook dinner a woman who
fed her kids like kings even when money
was tight my fantastic mum I love what
you used to do with the leftover oxtail
soup it's amazing how you used to make
it stretch for like five or six dinners
I don't exactly it's not that bad mum
and I are cooking a classic Thrifty main
course of braised oxtail but with a
Chinese twist and we're sticking in the
East with an oriental put chili poached
pears with star anise dust look at this
lovely these are my ultimate Thrifty
recipes breakfast lunch and dinner
starting with the breakfast that's cheap
as chips but never fails to Delight
irresistible cinnamon eggy bread with
quick stewed apples
I've never forgotten I think I was about
six years of age when mum brought this
huge tray of eggy bread to the table and
it was like wow man we've died and gone
to heaven start off with a slightly
stale bread
four or five day old loaf left over if
it's a fresh bread then it absorbs too
much of the egg so therefore it gets
soggy you never get it fried and Crisp
And if you're not going to use the
breadcrumbs eggy bread is a must
in France they call it pan Perdue the
Lost loaf
now eggy bread is great on its own but
serving it with stewed apples is
delicious so the secret here
keep the skins on a lot of flavor in the
skin and also it stops the Apple from
breaking down too quickly they have
these nice chunks as opposed to sort of
Apple puree
[Music]
now get your pan nice and hot and
sprinkle a couple of tablespoons of
sugar
take the sugar down to a light caramel
it's quite incredible how cheap it is to
make this and yet it was so filling
if you haven't got apples this recipe
will work pretty much with any fruit
you've got in
it's a mix a pear and an apple a banana
and a pineapple just chew it lightly
tossing the caramel get a little knob of
butter
that makes a nice toffee Apple flavor
really simple
now
you can see what's happening the apples
are caramelizing but they're staying
intact because the skins on the apple
and the caramels turn into this nice
rich butterscotch sauce
once you've glazed all the apples a
couple of tablespoons of water in there
bring that to the ball and let that cook
out now the eggs
three whole eggs
what's got the eggs
add about four tablespoons of milk you
want the egg thick and Rich
and then lightly sprinkle in a couple
tablespoons of sugar that sweetens up
the mixture and when you start frying
the bread
caramelizes it usually a teaspoon of
powdered cinnamon that gives the bread
that really nice spicy deliciousness
apples are glazing beautifully
and put them on a low heat and get a pan
on now for the bread
spoon of oil and stops the butter from
burning butter in
so that starts frothing get your bread
in it's going to be pretty quick now now
you don't leave the bread soak it
train
and in the pan
foreign
[Music]
has browned flip it over
90 seconds each side that butter gives
that nice golden brown color of the egg
[Music]
absolutely beautiful
it's quite remarkable isn't it a couple
of eggs splash of milk leftover apples
and all of a sudden you've got this
stunning breakfast
[Music]
now my apples they've all glazed
beautifully
get a nice spoon of that amazing juice
and drizzle that over
wow if my mum saw me doing this she'd
kill me you're getting all Posh again
I'm using a touch of ice sugar to make
it look stunning
not for me takes me back to when I was
six years of age
and I thought
I just won the lottery that is
incredible
thank you Brad
[Music]
you won't get more breakfast for your
buck my mum's incredibly delicious
cinnamon eggy bread with quick stewed
apples
[Music]
knowledge is crucial if you want to make
sure you're getting the best ingredients
for your money
so to help you shop smarter here's a
closer look at some of the key
ingredients I'll be cooking with today
[Music]
deliciously seductive in asani and great
for adding flavor and texture to Thrifty
dishes because a little goes a long long
way my favorite bacon is traditional
cured Italian pancetta rich and strong
in flavor it brings extra depth of
salads stews and soups but a great cheap
alternative is streaky bacon and it's
what I'll be using for my Thrifty lunch
star anise is an aromatic anacidi
star-shaped pod widely used in Chinese
cooking fantastic simmered in Savory
broths or infused in sweet puddings star
anise is widely available in
supermarkets but for the Thrifty it can
be bought in bulk from special Asian
Grocers properly stalled in an airtight
container the pods will last for several
months
oxtail is pretty much what it says on
the tin the tail bones of a bull or cow
perhaps it's best known guys is as
oxtail soup but this cut is also a great
value for money choice for braising
if you shop around it's hard to find a
cheaper cut of red meat
long and slow they'll yield anxious
chunks of melt in your mouth beef I'll
be cooking mine Chinese style for a
delicious Thrifty dinner
my ultimate Thrifty lunch would always
be a soup soups are really versatile and
great fusing up ingredients you've
already got but best of all I absolutely
love them
and this is one of my favorites a
comforting Smoky bacon sweet corn and
potato soup
Thrifty for me is about ingredients that
are in the cupboard
Smoky bacon onions potatoes sweet corn
it's amazing how cheap the ingredients
are they go into this
get your bacon and just cut into nice
chunks I want these nice bite-sized
pieces Smoky chunky and just absolutely
delicious it's almost like an American
corn chowder
potatoes give it starch thickness sweet
corn gives it that glossy delicious
flavor a couple of Baileys they're
always hanging around if they're not in
your cupboard they're on someone's drive
so ask to borrow them they are so
powerful and it goes brilliantly well
with the onions and the bacon Bailey's
in
a couple of potatoes
incredible how far you can stretch
something out especially when you bulk
it with potatoes slice them
and dice them nice and chunky
soups are a fantastic way to use up
leftover veg or meat that might
otherwise go to waste and if you make it
in bulk freeze it in individual portions
and save on lunches throughout the week
so you can see already how hearty and
robust the soup is it's a delicious
combination onions bacon potatoes and
now
some fresh leeks
open up the leak into four
give that a nice wash
leeks often have soil left in their tops
so it's important to clean them
thoroughly start sweating that down
we haven't even got a corn in there yet
and already it's looking and smelling
incredible
add salt but remember you've got bacon
in there which is salty so proceed with
caution
really important to sweat those potatoes
off I love getting that flavor from the
Smoky bacon
in with the potatoes
now once the leak is cut it off
creamed corn
a popular side dish in the states cream
corn is made from fresh frozen or even
tin corn cooked with onion butter and
cream and can be bought ready made that
starts to give the foundation the soup
half the cream corn and the sweet corn
then you stop
don't flood the soup
just bring the stock to underneath the
ingredients you can always add very
different to take away
homemade chicken stock is so cheap to
make just boil up your roast chicken
bones with a few fresh veg and freeze in
batches for when you need it lighten the
load with a touch of milk that gives a
really nice bright color
now bring that up to the ball turn it
down and let it simmer for 12 to 15
minutes
as it Cooks slowly the starch thickens
the soup the bacon renders and that leek
onion starts to puree and the corn just
shines
okay next we're going to make the
American cheese biscuits in the UK
they're known as scones but in America
they're called biscuits
[Music]
[Applause]
first put plain flour into a sieve
add baking powder and sift both into a
bowl
next add some salt
pepper and grated mature cheddar cheese
mix the dry ingredients then make it
well in the center
pour in double cream and gently combine
with a wooden spoon
turn your dough out onto a floured
surface and knead for a few seconds only
if you overwork it your cheese biscuits
won't rise
run out your dough to about two
centimeter thick and cut into four
centimeter round biscuits
[Applause]
he's well apart on a lined baking sheet
and leave to rest on the tray for about
10 minutes then brush the top of each
biscuit with melted butter and bake for
about 30 minutes at 160 degrees C in a
preheated oven
when your cheese biscuits are well risen
and a beautiful golden brown remove
deliciously Moorish served hot or cold
time to Dole out my Thrifty lunch
I always like to leave a soup to stand
or rest it looks richer gets rid of all
the stock I like to have two-thirds
ingredients one third of the stock so it
looks like a nice delicious Chunky Soup
into the bowl
[Music]
beautiful tin sweet corn a leek potato
and some streaky bacon but it doesn't
look like it's just come out of a
stalker but that is proper hearty food
[Music]
served with my American style cheese
biscuits this Thrifty lunch may have
been made on a shoestring but without an
ounce of compromise on freshness and
flavor
[Music]
one person who knows all about being
Thrifty in the home kitchen it's my mum
God I love you I love you too now you're
gonna help me cook dinner and give me
some valuable tips on how to save money
and help get you right I will do you
will do Excellency easy peasy
for my ultimate Thrifty dinner we're
gonna make an amazing spicy braised
oxtail followed by a deliciously juicy
pudding chili poached pears with star
and East dust now oxtail is something
that we grew up with yeah there's
something you can do in the morning and
put it in the oven because it has to be
cooked really really slow yes I'm gonna
dust this in flour it's amazing how many
chefs are using oxtail on their menus
today it's incredible it's fairly
popular it's fairly cheap as well it's
amazing I used to make it stretch for
like five or six dinners I don't exactly
it's not that bad now I know why we're
also skinny growing up
it wasn't that bad I'm joking come on
you know I'm joking but you see
sometimes we went to the butcherson you
had maybe extra two or three I used to
put in a saucepan and you had love to
stop for soup what was that spicy soup
that really nice
and I used to make a good pot of scotch
broth Scott's broth I remember now I'll
peel a couple cloves of garlic no I'll
show you a quick way of getting that out
get your knife and just wash it a mess
peel them and I'll crush them in the
garnet Crusher thank you
all right oxtail in
I'm gonna fry that off you can get that
nice and brown and we've all braised it
in red wine and sort of chicken stock
before but I'm gonna get this done with
a Chinese influence the Chinese
absolutely love cooking oxtail
you started cooking at home quite early
on right 17 and a half 17 and a half
your mum died quite young very young 26
26 so who taught you how to cook
enough to tell you I think you just
learn as you get older and you learn by
your mistakes and then enjoy it yes I
did enjoy it yeah that was a nice
vegetable not the fennel fennel isn't it
that lovely that's beautiful yeah a lot
of people do use it a lot of them use it
in salads but no one actually Cooks it
if you just slice that up man
now these are nice and brown
you look lovely yeah put the color on
there
you just sliced up the chili okay just
size it down I'll keep the seeds in
there because I want some heat as well
one thing he never used to do was work
with many spices there wasn't many
Chinese influences I wasn't very
adventurous with spicy Spike then no I
like ginger do you I love Ginger
especially fresh yeah coriander seeds a
little handful ten yeah
and soy sauce
and quite generous in soy sauce like
four or five tablespoons that helps give
it that saltiness and a nice dark Rich
color on the vegetables so as it braises
the meat tenderizes quicker I would
never do anything fennel and
the chilies and but it smells lovely
does that smell nice
and then a little bit of this this is a
rice wine vinegar yeah
what other tips would you give me in
order to save money on cooking what got
you through that tough time feeding all
six of us and holding two jobs
an hour and a half
then I would think right I'll make a
race putting up an apple pie and for the
same sort of heat use the other shelf in
the oven so you weren't just watching
the pennies in terms of the produce you
also cutting down the gas bill yeah wow
super Nan yeah yeah Superman yeah some
oxtail back on top of the vegetables
okay top that up is that beef beef here
is that vegetable stock no a really nice
chicken stock why are you putting
chicken stock isn't it because it's
quite a sort of light fragrant way of
cooking oxtail because oxtail itself is
quite Rich yeah chicken Stock's nice and
light just cover it with stock lovely
color isn't it it's a beautiful color
and it will taste there we go big deep
breath okay man
well that's lovely I can taste the
fennel on that is that nice that's
lovely
oh Jesus
damn water Finance
take some water now it's not water is it
water come on well mum recovers from the
kick of the chili to go with my Oriental
influenced oxtail I'm going to knock up
a quick fresh radish salad
take a bunch of radishes and separate
off the edible leaves
once washed thoroughly Place half the
radishes in the bowl with the leaves
chop the remaining radishes in half and
add them too
[Music]
next peel and finely slice a banana
shallot add them to the radishes and
Seasons with salt and pepper
dress with a good squeeze of fresh lemon
juice and a drizzle of olive oil
then mix
radish salad it's that simple
Next Up dessert delicious poached pears
I Love Pears ready so we're going to
poach them with a little bit of chili
chili never heard of that a little bit
of saffron no no
pan on
take off a little slice like that so
they stand up nicely and then peel
okay then and then the chili yeah hold
that up and just go down yeah
it's true
and open that up okay into the water
seeds in as well seeds in as well
oh hello holes what is that smell it
smells so good we've got the most
amazing
are you well yeah
we making that so we're gonna poach
these pears a little bit of chili water
and sugar what are they holes
it's exactly that saffron is expensive
but you only need the tiniest little bit
a little pinch to make that water go
light and golden star needs
I want all that flavor coming out of the
chili we're gonna make
the most amazing star in East dust
Starry Stars dust did you get your Star
Nissan
[Music]
seeds yeah and then you start grinding
a little teaspoon of Ginger give it a
nice mix thank you mate and that's going
to dust the top of the pears once
they're cooked right get your pears
drop them in there
[Music]
and that's what we're going to sprinkle
Ginger and star anise wow the rice is
that really good oh it's lovely isn't it
so once they're cooked cooled down
sprinkle that over the top right have
you guys got homework yes
thank you guys
after an eight minute simmer our pairs
should be ready no just get your knife
on the knife through and see how easy
the knife is
so that means they're soft and cooked
now you can't leave them in that
overnight two or three days all right
and they just get darker and More
Beautiful the good thing about the
cooking liquor is that you don't throw
that away because you can use that again
for reproaching
peaceful and when they look impressive
don't they
[Music]
it's lovely isn't it because they're
amazing
and just
doesn't
and then take your little
star in East dust
and just
dust
over this lovely now for my favorite
part
the oxtail wow
look at that
is beautiful
I love the way you see that just all
sliding down the bone
the wasting that at all
at all please none
yeah we do lovely and all right I'll
grab that that is beautiful
this is my ultimate Thrifty dinner so
just slow cooked Chinese braised oxtail
with a light and peppery radish salad
followed by gorgeous chili poached pears
with star anise dust
Jack Polly Tilly Megan look at this time
to see what you think
it's delicious yeah nice mum what do you
think that's Lovely isn't it
remains gone by a lot of people just
lift it up and eat it with them
no has anyone saved room for delicious
stunning pears we have the
good to see you super now
there are loads more great home cooking
recipes on my app cook with me you can
find it in the App Store good luck